mesa's end is a card that sat in the
back of my trade binder as well as in
the back of my mind for 10 years simply
get 10 Gates and then you win the game
it was always an intriguing card in the
way most alternate wincons are but I
could never find a good reason to build
a M's end deck ever so often I'd come
back to it most notably to ponder a
child of aara commander deck early last
year but it wasn't until September that
I finally found a good vehicle for it
see the issue with Mesa end is that it's
both visible and slow
opponents can track the progress of the
deck to its wicon with pinpoint accuracy
and the time frame to arrive at that
windc con leaves a long period where
opponents can apply pressure in addition
the 10 gate requirement means that deck
builders are encouraged to play a
sequence of pretty mediocre tap lands or
else need to activate M's end a large
number of times however there is a way
to get around all these problems what if
I simply played all the gates at once
cards like scape shift and reshape the
Earth allow deck builders to do just
this getting all the next gates for M's
end out all at once this can leave a
turn cycle before Victory due to the
lands entering tapped unless a player
has an amulet of vigor in play or rather
an untapped Turtle friend causing all
other permanence to enter either tapped
or untapped depending on his own status
Aros is a fantastic vehicle for this
sort of deck because not only is he a
combo enabler he can also help out with
ramping faster as well as slowing down
opponents in addition to running 12
gates the deck ended up running several
bounce lands to give a Mana boost with
the commander some Basics to be grabbed
with land grabbing spells and handful of
other utility lands for a grand total of
43 not including M's end of the two
cards that allow the deck to win one
costs nine mana and the other requires
10 lands so naturally ramp ends up being
a very big part of the deck there are 20
dedicated ramp spells as well as an
additional four ramp spells that serve
double duty by also offering a way to
tap down the commander and being able to
force everyone's stuff to enter tapped
until my next turn is a pretty sweet
side benefit from there the deck mostly
consists of draw tutors and interaction
the most potent of the deck's tutors is
emergent ultimatum a card that basically
serves as an additional combo piece
since any combination of reshaped the
earth scape shift and boundless Realms
will result in getting enough lands to
win as far as interaction goes I always
like to have a lot of counter spells in
my blue combo decks so this deck runs 11
of those and six other cards intended to
control the state of the game in some
capacity the deck took lot of tweaking
to get it to the point where it
functioned appropriately how much ramp
how much draw what sort of lands how
should the deck go about surviving and
preventing opponents from winning how
important is the commander and how much
should I be leveraging him for non-combo
purposes I spent several weeks and
dozens of hours tweaking and tuning and
pruning and answering tough questions
until I'd finally achieved the seemingly
impossible a deck that could pull off a
mazes end win consistently by turn seven
or eight with plenty of interaction held
up all for a bit over a hundred bucks it
was an accomplishment a realization of
my past Ambitions an optimized
utilization of a silly alternate wicon
card I'd been thinking about for 10
whole years and if the story ended here
it would be an unambiguously happy one
an uncomplicated tale of
self-actualization and cardboard Triumph
however it was in fact somewhat
Complicated by a simple fact Magic the
Gathering is a card game and decks are
meant to be played in games against
people in my first few games with the
deck I was kind of surprised with the
way people responded to me pulling off
my massive land swing I'd get excited
and start grabbing Gates and other
people would basically go oh you got the
combo okay cool another game I had
constructed a grand narrative for this
deck because it was genuinely
challenging to build but in an actual
game of Commander this plays just like
any other one card plus Commander combo
deck satisfy conditions get pieces stop
Opps from winning long enough to put
things together protect combo and do the
combo it's not necessarily that the deck
was entirely uninteresting or entirely
devoid of fun gameplay it's an
acceptable combo deck the real surprise
was the expectation versus the reality
of the situation I had constructed
narratives of grandeur as I was reaching
out striving for a powerful maz's end
deck but once it was in my hand it was
clearly something far more mundane than
I had expected and on some level it's a
little strange that this happened to me
because I had watched my friend Hans
have a very similar experience a few
months prior building a yidris deck this
was a deck that used yidris unique
combat damage ability to Cascade into an
each opponent discards their hand you
draw 28 cards combo off of two cantrips
it was otherwise built in a mid-range
shell containing ramp removal value
engines and some very specific
protection spells that were chosen in
order to still get value when they were
cascaded into so what's the problem
there well once again despite having a
creative execution the next combo was
still a combo and opponent treated it as
such in fact this deck was even more
problematic than the Aros deck due to
the fact that all of its Shenanigans
could be stopped by simply killing or
fully blocking the yidris and since not
doing that meant possibly seeding a
massive value swing to the yidris player
players would religiously hate out the
yidris on paper everything lined up for
the deck but real life is not made out
of paper a question I've asked myself is
what are these decks saying exactly they
say something about Combos and about
humans and about how we build decks but
that's not the most interesting thing
they say the most interesting thing
these goofy combo decks tell me is that
deck building creativity is not rewarded
in and of itself in commander games that
might sound like the whining of some
hipster but I'm not intending that
statement as any sort of value judgment
about the state of the game rather it
provides an interesting jumping off
point for thinking more critically about
the game and how it's experienced by the
people who play it an inherent weirdness
of a collectible card game like magic
the Gathering is that deck building and
playing are two separate phases of the
game you're not not playing Dominion or
some other card game where deck building
and playing happen in tandem no these
things are clearly demarcated limited
formats provide the most conventionally
game-like structure for these phases in
the sense that a four or 5H hour limited
event literally contains separate timed
phases for assembling decks and playing
the game a magic the Gathering draft
where players pick cards from packs in a
circle and build decks with their
resulting card pool before entering a
series of timed rounds actually
resembles a lot of board and card games
in structure as a simple example for
sale is a game that contains one phase
where players bid against each other on
property cards and then a second phase
where players use their lineup of
properties to secure Point cards like a
magic the Gathering draft the first
phase involves a mixture of strategy and
luck to determine how good a player's
group of cards is and then the second
phase uses the quality of that group as
well as some further strategy and luck
to determine the ultimate outcome of the
game this is a clear enough line to draw
with limited Magic Gathering events but
the relationship between these different
phases gets aggressively more convoluted
from here let's think about a low-level
standard event in the deck building
phase players on their own time and in
their own spaces complete the task of
assembling the best standard deck they
can and the best sideboard to face off
against the decks they expect to face
then the playing Phase sees the players
now congregating in a game store at a
specific time play a sequence of games
to determine a winner this is very
different from most games in that the
different phases occur in different
settings on different timelines but the
structure is still roughly the same the
first phase sees players complete one
goal which then contributes to the
outcome of a second goal however taking
things a step further into the realm of
Commander things get even murkier
because you lose a lot of the element of
competitiveness the first phase does
still involve building a deck and the
second phase does still involve playing
that deck but the goals are less clear
unlike a standard tournament there isn't
usually a prize for winning an EDH game
aside from bragging rights and even in
store run casual Commander events the
subject of prize support is one with no
shortage of disagreement and controversy
but simply winning isn't codified as a
goal in the same way as it is in 60c
card constructed events this difference
in how winning is perceived then
trickles back down to the deck building
phase if everybody was sincerely trying
their best to make the most powerful
deck in that deck building phase
commander games would be full of net
deck C EDH lists but most players choose
to show up to EDH games with Decks that
look quite different than that winning
will be a contributing factor to the
sorts of decks that EDH players will
build but it will be accompanied by a
malange of other factors rendered subtle
in competitive 1v1 form
wanting a deck to do a certain cool play
wanting to have a deck feel a certain
way wanting a deck to look a certain way
wanting a deck to produce the funniest
moments and so on a lot of these goals
will mesh well with the task of having
fun in that second phase the playing
Phase obviously players playing Decks
that feel expressive or cool to them in
some way will usually lead to them
having more fun and the goal of winning
will likewise produce a lot of fun
moments for people however there are
also goals that don't mesh as well with
having fun in a game of commander and
the best example of these is Dex that
try to win in some especially creative
or expressive way as it turns out
winning the game is generally a pretty
brief process a long period of back and
forth can be fun but when a game reaches
a point where one person is all but
guaranteed to win it's generally for the
best that things stop very soon after
this is also why non-deterministic combo
or lockout decks are often unpopular
they stretch out the length of a win
requiring opponents to make an
unfortunate choice either concede to
save time or waste an extra 10 minutes
on the 5% % chance that the comboing
player Fizzles but okay I'm getting off
topic the platonic ideal of an EDH win
is brief there is no ceremony where the
winning player gets to Revel in their
glory and be celebrated for their deck
building or gameplay accomplishments the
game just ends and people move on to
either another game or any of the other
things that might occupy their life
winning in that creative way might be
cool for that first time or two but
maybe not even that the really memorable
games are usually the ones where
something unexpected happens not the on
where a player trots out their
creatively devised wicon they spent
hours creating but spending hours to
creatively devise and perfect a wicon
still has an alert to it doesn't it
despite understanding all of what I just
said I have a pattern of continually
coming back to build new creative combo
decks it's an itch that I can't seem to
stop scratching another one I built in
paper a few months back was one I like
to call tribal fiend Hunter the basic
idea behind it was this you know fiend
Hunters those creatures that Exile
something else until they leave play
well what if you built a deck with the
goal of getting three of them and then
having them Exile each other repeatedly
in an indefinitely long Loop just a few
fellas having a really phenomenal day of
fiend hunting this is a somewhat unique
spin on a combo deck instead of finding
a handful of different pieces in
separate categories you just need to
find three of the eight fiend Hunters
that exist within the green white color
identity the deck then wins through some
means or other a couple of the fiend
Hunters also create tokens or counters
and three of them Exile multiple cards
which allows for infinite ETB triggers
speaking of ETB triggers I went with the
commander choice of Torsten founder of
Balia Torsten has a lot of benefits with
the biggest one being that he draws a
bunch of cards on ETB a fact which can
be paired with cards that flicker in
order to draw the number of cards that
the deck needs to draw in order to find
three fiend Hunters 37 on average so the
deck begins with a mixture of fiend
hunters and sources of Blink from there
most of the deck ended up being occupied
by lands and ramp creatures 42 and 29
respectively
this might seem like a lot because it is
I have a seven Mana Commander I want to
cast and since he's the only source of
draw in a deck that wants to draw a ton
of cards the deck doesn't really do
anything before he gets cast the manad
dorks of the deck are carefully selected
to offer the most utility during the
fiend hunting combo step there are six
different ones that can give infinite
Mana infinite plus one plus one counters
or some other resource that can
hopefully lead to me winning and the
next removal likewise fits into this
mold overall the goal here was to have a
combo deck that is as flu fluid and
flexible as possible using the power of
fiend Hunters to creatively piece
together winds in a variety of different
ways initially I considered using some
price year cards in the deck like
Preston the vanisher or even switching
the commander to a traxa for a
four-color version but eventually I came
to the conclusion that I did not want to
spend more than $50 on this deck the
logic was this I knew that I found the
fiend Hunter combo funny but I had been
down the funny combo road before and the
resulting deck didn't end up feeling
fully worth the money I spent on it with
that in mind I figured there would be
two reasonably likely possibilities
either this deck ended up being a
hilarious blast to play and I'd keep
finding reasons to pull it out a
situation worth well more than $50 to me
or it did end up being a novelty that
I'd get a handful of funny games out of
before more or less being sheld a
situation worth around $50 sure enough
the reality of the situation was far
closer to the lad the deck functioned
pretty amusingly once it was up and
going and it would typically combo off
around turn seven which isn't half bad
for a $50 deck but this came with a
catch the seven Mana commander and the
fact that all of the ramp was
creature-based meant that the deck was
extremely disruptable killing a couple
manad dorks in the first few turns of
the game would immediately set the deck
back several turns this deck was
carefully crafted with just barely
enough of Any Given resource to function
and this ended up being its biggest
weakness the deck just has too many
possible ways to kneecap it in order to
keep up in most high power casual games
the deck wasn't a total failure it was a
successive budget deck building and a
success of my own ability to show
restraint and know when I shouldn't
spend too much on a deck however it was
still yet another goofy combo deck that
didn't really succeed at being a deck
I'd want to play with long term the Aros
deck and the fiend Hunter deck are the
only two I've built in paper but there
are several other goofy combo decks I've
workshopped and considered online deck
lists for over the past several months
there was that polymorph deck whose only
three creatures were trench gorger B
trade spy and time stream Navigator with
the goal being to Mill my entire library
before taking infinite turns there was
that Brian Lind Dargo deck that had the
goal casting Dargo a large number of
times before doing something I honestly
don't remember what at this point there
was also that time a patron deck sent me
down a rabbit hole of trying to build
Rog storm a deck with the goal of
casting Rog an arbitrarily large number
of times before jessing my opponents for
some absurd amount I've had enough sense
not to build any of these three in paper
but still why do I keep finding myself
in this place again and again
fundamentally I think it comes down to
looking for a sense of accomplishment
let's go back to the two phases model of
Magic the gaing gameplay
unlike a 60 card constructed tournament
where winning is the number one goal
during the playing stage of things
outside of cedh there can be any number
of goals during this phase of a
commander game each holding varying
levels of priority winning will be one
for most players but beyond that players
kind of need to pick out what they're
looking for from a game are they trying
to have a fun social experience are they
trying to impress other players to do a
cool thing are they trying to mimic a
game of Uno are they trying to assemble
the largest collection of women looking
left in the Western Hemisphere
ultimately players end up creating their
own goals for the playing Phase of
things either consciously or
unconsciously and these goals will then
serve as a guiding force during their
deck building phase an underrated factor
that I'd guess affects almost all
players in this format is aimlessness
the human brain goes a little wonky when
it doesn't have enough structure to
guide it through any given task at hand
and for a lot of players the amount of
structure that the commander format
provides is an amount that puts them in
that wonk Zone it's not hard to figure
out why the format contains almost every
card ever printed and doesn't have set
in stone parameters for what decks
should do or how power powerful they
should be for newer players in the
format building with what they have on
hand trying to build the strongest deck
possible will likely keep them occupied
for a while and this is indeed quite
often to see with players who have just
discovered the format and are looking to
explore the limits of what they can do
with it this is because player skill
budgetary restrictions and card pool
frictions can serve as limitations
things a player will be optimizing
against whether they're aware of it or
not even after players have gotten to
the point where they're capable of
building more powerful decks than they
could previously they will often times
still seek out limitations in some form
or other such as budget aesthetic
mechanical or otherwise these sorts of
limitations can be quite helpful for
maintaining a sense of focus while deck
building I frequently build with a
budget restriction of some sort as this
has dual benefits of preventing me from
spending more than I want as well as
giving me a parameter to optimize
against I have an extra too many words
to say about the subject of constrained
optimization as applied to Magic the
Gathering that would derail this video
with a torrent of tangentially related
Matthew so that stuff is going
to be in an extra posted over on my
patreon long story short constraints can
provide a nice guiding hand hand in the
deck building process and they can
present goals that allow players to have
more fun while building decks however
they will often times be less felt
within a game building a Volo deck you
might choose to have all your creatures
be different types and that might pose a
fun challenge during the deck building
process but once you're in an actual
game odds are you're just going to be
playing generic snowbally mid-range
likewise building decks with the goal of
accomplishing cool or unique play
patterns can be a fun puzzle to solve
during the deck building phase but once
you're playing an actual game that cool
plan won't NE necessarily translate into
an interesting game so what does
translate into an interesting game well
when I look at all my decks there are
two Decks that stand out as being the
most consistently fun ones for me my R
deck a greedy Cascade battle cruiser
deck and my Sher slide deck a cycling
based toolbox control deck those two
decks Share three key attributes
consistency flexibility and resiliency
by consistency I simply mean that these
decks always do something they don't
generally have bad games and they are
always doing something to further their
game plan by flexibility I mean that
what precisely these decks are doing can
vary a lot and can be shaped to the game
they happen to end up in though both
decks lean toward late game domination
they also both have ways to put on some
pressure if there's another deck that is
at risk of getting too far ahead finally
by resiliency I mean that these decks
are hard to fully shut down myata deck
is iconically resilient due to its focus
on basic lands a seldom hated resource
nothing short of reducing this deck's
life total to zero will really shut it
down the shroom slide deck is somewhat
more hatable but it is still fairly
resilient due to how many different ways
it has of building resources it has a
graveyard plan it has an artifacts plan
it has an astral slide ETB flicker plan
it has a flying creature Beatdown plan
and it has a hand sculpting control plan
there are just so many elements working
in tandem that if one or two get knocked
out the deck can simply pick a different
direction to build advantage in you may
find different deck attributes to be
enjoyable than I do but these are just
three that have proved most consistently
fun for me and they're a good starting
place if you're not yet sure what you
find fun a final additional element that
these decks share is that their engines
and interaction Suites are well defined
but their wincons are less well defined
because they're both late game decks the
r deck is looking to build up an absurd
land count and then win and the shirom
slide deck is a control deck that wants
to gain a degree of dominance over the
state of the game before it finishes off
opponents to me this goes back to the
length of windc cons because these decks
have States they're trying to achieve
rather than discret plans to win the
game winning games is more of an
involved process than it is in most of
my other decks whereas with a lot of
decks the win is quite rapid once the
deck is in a good position with a slower
more controlling deck there will be more
time to simmer in the win that's
certainly more enjoyable for me while
playing commander and I think it's
useful to identify that but I hesitate
to call it an unambiguous good is it
good for the table if I always pull out
this sort of grindy end game deck is it
good for me to always pick this sort of
fun optimized play experience for myself
at the end of the day there is a valid
place for novelty decks out there in
spite of everything I'm ultimately glad
I built both my turtle Gates deck and my
fend Hunter deck they were fun to build
and it's nice to have a bit of extra
variety around if I'm ever starting to
bore of my first or second string decks
it's valid to have different Decks that
serve different desires and not every
deck needs to be some sort of optimal
construct of mathematically maximized
fund value it's even valid to build a
deck primarily for the enjoyment of
building it and whether or not it ends
up materializing in paper can be a
matter of personal preference what I
would advocate for however is
mindfulness when you're building a deck
it's good to calibrate your expectations
and understand what the deck is going to
mean for you get to know yourself what
do you find fun what goals do you strive
for in the gameplay stage of things and
how can you contribute to those goals in
the deck building stage is it worthwhile
to introduce constraints and how will
those constraints affect the gameplay
portion of things as compared to the
deck building portion because ultimately
a holistic understanding of the game
needs to include both of these things
deck building is playing Magic on some
level it's just playing Magic in a
different way than the games themselves
and to different ends thanks for
watching this was an expansion on a
patron only video I released about 7
months ago I finally felt like I had
enough to say to turn it into a full
length video if you want to see me chew
on ideas weeks or months before they end
up in a public video you can support me
over on patreon my lovely patrons some
of whom are on screen now allow me to
take time on longer videos such as this
one and without even needing to put
midwell ads on them beyond that if
you're feeling inspired to buy some
funny combo cards or non-funny non-combo
cards I left an affiliate link for TCG
player in the description all right bye